bsb bullies on the way so you're
breeding dogs yeah that's a fact
so um who's okay this might be a random
super paws question
but when you i have a dog then i'm gonna
start breeding right well i'm gonna
start studying them out mm-hmm
who is jerking off your dog don't juggle
your dog you gotta take it to the uh
take it to the um so my boy does it
himself and he makes like 300 grand a
year jerk and he'd be jerking his dog
off but i'm like bro i'm not touching no
dicks for no amount of money doug
whatever you can't touch the dog dick
no i'm not saying no dicks in life like
i mean it's a dog even like even like if
i got to change my kid's diaper it's a
lot of baby wipes i've never fizzed my
my fingers ain't touching anything i
just what i'm curious because i just got
a frenchie that's like a puppy man i'm
like oh am i going to have to jerk this
dog no you can take it to the vet and
then you the vet will drink the dog
exactly unless and they'll leave you you
get to get the [ __ ] in there the special
man and you be out but like you got to
think how much is it worth for you is it
you that's what i look at if if a
[ __ ] try to you know hey i'm
going to save myself for 150 dollars and
yeah
if
150 bucks i'm paying the 150. but then
it's like i'll pay the 150 to someone i
know to jerk the dog off just oh you got
to shoot a list because they not even
yeah and then i could i could hold it
over their head forever like bro you
jerked off
a camera yeah because they're not a
certified jerk offer so you gotta charge
them less you know what i mean
but yeah i i think um yeah i'm not
joking off no dogs at all
uh lead at the joe buttons man oh my
goodness